best actor a really superb performance
is an actor getting out of his own way
trusting that the character he's playing
has a life of its own and allowing that
character to be what it must be the five
actors nominated tonight have
accomplished just that for his role as a
man consumed by envy of Wolfgang Mozart
in Amadeus F Murray Abraham
as a being from another planet with much
to teach us in Starman Jeff Bridges
for his portrait of a man driven to
self-destruction in under the volcano
Albert Finney
in the title role of the immortal
musical prodigy Amadeus Tom Howe
and as the American reporter whose life
has changed forever by the war in
Southeast Asia in the killing field Sam
Waterson
the winner is f Murray
yeah it would be a lie if I told you I
didn't know what to say because I've
been working on this speech for about 25
years
but you were not going to hear any of
those speeches because I none of the
speeches were less than 45 seconds you
know it's a it's easy to gamble
everything when you've got nothing to
lose and melosh Foreman had a great deal
to lose when he gave these brilliant
roles to Tom House and me and his
courage became my inspiration there's
only one thing that's missing for me
tonight and that is to have Tom Hall
standing by my side
wait I still have more time wait half of
this statue belongs to my beloved wife
Kate thank you
you